E imagino que mis hijos van a vivir en un tiempo
en el que los bienes más preciados serán el agua fresca y la empatía.
Amo los bailes preciosos y las esculturas majestuosas
tanto como cualquier otro,
pero denme algo más para seguir.
Levántenme con estética sublime
y denme herramientas para convertir esa inspiración
en comprensión y acción.
Por ejemplo, soy un director de teatro que ama los deportes.
Cuando estaba haciendo mi última obra /peh-LO-tah/
Pensé mucho como el futbol era un medio para mi familia inmigrante
para crear un sentido de continuidad y normalidad y comunidad
dentro del nuevo contexto en EE. UU.
En estos momentos de elevada xenofobia y ataques a la identidad inmigrante,
quería pensar
como el juego podría servir como herramienta de afirmación
para estadounidenses de primera generación y niños inmigrantes,
para pedirles que consideren los patrones de movimiento en el campo
como los patrones de movimiento en grupos sociales y frontera.
Futbolistas o no,
los inmigrantes en EE. UU. juegan en un campo peligroso.
Quería ayudar a entender a los niños
que el mismo músculo que utilizan para planear el siguiente gol
también puede ser usado para navegar la siguiente cuadra.
Para mí, la libertad existe en el cuerpo. Hablamos de ella
de forma abstracta e incluso de manera divisoria,
como "protejamos nuestra libertad," "construyamos este muro,"
"nos odian por nuestra libertad."
Tenemos todos estos sistemas hermosamente diseñados
para encarcelarnos o deportarnos.
¿Pero cómo designamos libertad?
Para estos niños, quería darles la idea de que existe algo dentro
que nadie les puede quitar,
así que desarrollé este programa escolar
que es parte clase de ciencias políticas y parte torneo de futbol,
dentro de un festival de artes.
Se accede al campo de investigación de /peh-LO-tah/
con el objetivo de crear acción política para jóvenes basada en los deportes.
El proyecto se llama "Moviendo y pasando."
Esto une el desarrollo de currículo, el rendimiento específico por área
y la política de la felicidad,
mientras se utiliza el futbol como una metáfora para la pregunta urgente
sobre la emancipación entre la juventud inmigrante.
Imaginen que son un niño de 15 años de Honduras
que ahora vive en Harlem.
O una niña de 13 años nacida en DC de dos inmigrantes nigerianos.
Amas el juego.
Estás en el campo con tus padres.
Acabas de entrenar el llevar la pelota entre conos
durante 15 minutos,
y entonces, de pronto, una banda de marcha baja al campo.
Y quieren asociar la emoción del juego con la exuberancia de cultura,
y localizar el sitio de emoción en el juego
en la misma coordenada física
de estar informado políticamente a través del arte,
con teatro para la liberación.
Pasamos una semana
viendo cómo el medio-campista explicaba Black Lives Matter,
o cómo el portero explicaba el control de armas,
o cómo el estilo de un defensa es la metáfora perfecta
para los límites del excepcionalidad estadounidense.
Mientras estudiamos la posiciones en el campo,
también nombramos e imaginamos nuestras propias libertades.
No lo sé, el futbol es, como,
lo único en este planeta sobre lo que todos estamos de acuerdo de hacer juntos.
¿Saben? Es como el deporte oficial de esta bola que gira.
Quiero poder conectar la emoción del juego
con el jugador de futbol incesante,
y conectar ese jugador de futbol
con los inmigrantes que también se movieron al ver una mejor posición.
Entre estos niños quiero conectar las historias de sus familias
con la felicidad del que anotó un gol,
la familia con ese sentimiento después de que la pelota vence al portero,
la cosa más cercana hacía la libertad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)